[Music]
this week we've got law school paparazzi
chase and battle royale hmm like a movie
I don't know like the game mode battle
royale now that's what all the kids like
right that's what's important man is
such a big part of my life and I don't
you play no he has kids my kids it's
literally the only their last two
birthdays and I have only one for your
birthday
Oh B bucks movie box man hey you gotta
be buck even the V bucks man it's
literally like that like the newsstands
B boxes love money you use on for
tonight same game currency how do you
not know this Isaac is obsessed before
tonight
he's not obsessed he's uh he's like he's
calm down so we I thought you said that
when you're nice and heated the kids
like you mean afford night man switch Oh
got it
he just got like the new Donkey Kong one
he's been about that one but like he
changed his games he's not like
obsessing over one my wife has my kids
they cannot play games on school nights
wow that's responsible man so like on
their game sis you monster I'm gonna use
kids as an excuse for me to play games
no no I tried that with my son and they
got so mad because I was like let me
play you're better Wario and I got
killed and they're just like get out of
my room my grandpa did that with us and
drinking we're talking about lawyers
here remember lying lawyers I love them
when they're on your side I love lawyers
you got a good one on your stuff Kim K
recently said that she's studying to
become who Kim Kardashian bro you say
Kim Kardashian's name and I'm
automatically irritated wait no I didn't
know what she says she wants to follow
in her dad's footsteps now is that her
lawyer outfit yes
her stay is cool that's her hair she's
like I'm gonna be in the world's first
wet lawyer 100% wet you can see her
trail as she walks in the court did it
like in you here are squishy shoes some
photos from her bow cuz her dad is a
lawyer that's why she wants one oh she
says that she really found a passion in
it after visiting president the
president at the White House yes she go
what's your name on the jail Kim
Kardashian being your legal counsel
you're going to jail no you're probably
not going to jail think about it dude
celebrity culture all the [ __ ] she's
gonna do you imagine her saying
objection do you know what an influencer
is kept yeah I think you do guess what
an influencer on the level of Kim
Kardashian could do to a [ __ ] jury
bro
she's very polarizing you could either
hate her or love her and like you got a
bet the bad jury loves to yeah but she
got the White House to release that
chick who was like in general that's not
a jury of her peers that are poorer than
her good point
you know what's the backstory on that
she went to go ask for clemency for
Alice Johnson who's a grandmother who
received a life sentence for a
first-time nonviolent drug offense what
tough yeah it's pretty bad and like I
guess they lobbied for Obama to do it
and then Obama didn't do it and then
Trump did it and then now Kim's like oh
[ __ ] this is kind of what I want to do
now exactly so she's saying that right
now she's doing like I want to help
people if I can get their lives back
watch your week long lawyer that has to
feel good now why is she going through
law school she wants to disable a school
she's gonna pass the bar she's doing an
apprenticeship at a law firm and she
will pet she'll take the bar in 2020 is
what she's saying that's the only a year
away
oh [ __ ] cuz I was gonna say she's that
genie she's like I have a lot of credits
okay when you do have that kind of money
though you can if you want to spend 20
hours every day now she's doing a
four-year apprenticeship right but if
you wanted to spend time on any type of
skill and you could spend like you know
whatever hours you want and not sleep
you could do it without worrying that
you're not gonna be able to pay the
bills or any
that's actually a fantastic point that's
money gives you the peace of mind that's
the only reason why I want to be rich
yeah the only reason why I want to be
rich is because I want to build mud huts
carefree without thinking about the
bills to pay that's a really profound
where's Joe bidding mine hunts for a
couple months
what I love about Joe's mud huts is that
he's not building them for anyone but
himself I need to get rich like you
build mud huts for myself
yeah he wants to be able to have the
like live in the wild but like know that
he's okay like he's okay he's saved you
guys are saying this as if it's normal
information like oh yeah Joe with the my
house in South Carolina no no my husband
on tinder is like would like to build my
those guys who's like I want to go to
Africa and but and then I want to help
myself by building [ __ ] for myself yeah
because the land is really cheap in
other countries so I might get some
really food build some stuff but maybe
visit it once every three years when I
get bored he's gonna make a sugarcane
juice called Joe's canes - yeah but it's
a nonprofit organization and I really
mean nonprofit by it's gonna lose money
so you know that's what it is I'm gonna
have a sugarcane farm just for me to
grow sugar cane yeah I don't care your
kids okay you can have it I'm gonna
provide jobs so people could work there
no and then when they're done they can
leave yeah and then they get paid but
I'm not gonna make I'm not gonna sell it
crap just like why are you doing this I
don't know you're gonna put sugar on top
of my I like watching things grow and
sugar canes grow really fast it's how to
make sugar cane jump and let me give you
a little tip you should check out
sunflowers just so you know check on
flowers yeah they grow real quick really
you could make too much money with
sunflowers I don't want that
my betters yes anyway Kim Kardashian
saying that a lot of this stuff is easy
for her the law is just like really easy
for me so what if she's like mad genius
but she's like Paris Hilton she could do
in her sleep she got a hundred is in
criminal law like the hardest like going
to the like going to court and like
doing criminal I don't know I need the
shittiest Nikki how dare you because you
you have a same kind of thing as Kim
where people look at you and they go
she's probably stupid I didn't say
anything no cuz you were just saying you
were just making fun of her with the
voice thing no that's my girl okay
how she talks I watch - and that's how
she talks - point so you're making fun
of my great impression like Paris Hilton
though she puts on that that's hot but
she's actually pretty genius
is she really well she created all these
companies yeah I didn't know that do you
think about the Hilton Brandon that
blonde girl is like an act we have a
friend that followed the same footsteps
yeah my cousin you know a Paris Hilton
Paris Hilton's footsteps as I like
coming off as really stupid but reality
is really fun because they're
non-threatening and then they also
create good controversy that's like
George W Bush dude everyone's like
always so stupid I'm like no dude this
guy's like a master war criminal I just
have you seen the movie Vice yeah man I
was like yo yo wild but even advice they
made him stupid because Dick Cheney was
the mastermind all mine yeah but I don't
buy that [ __ ] freakin overlook Cheney
and this dude was a master puppeteer I
don't buy that she got freakin rich Dick
Cheney was in charge he could he would
have gotten a pardon for scooter libby
but he couldn't cuz george w wouldn't
what i don't understand i was good
living he was a part of this little
investigation thing back in the day but
he was want to change these guys and he
ended up getting he had like a felony
and indictment against him or something
and then bush community center
oh he's so stupid I think he's a master
war criminal what she wants to go visit
this is crazy our generation right a
reality TV star with the reality TV star
that got famous by [ __ ] a [ __ ]
musician on camera yeah
and her dad is a lawyer for all Jay
Simpson mm-hm out that everything is
connected anyone dude Rob Kardashian
kicked ass for him yeah he was a beast
is it this crazy and there's a show
about that they turn everything to
energy I was good to the old a Simpsons
show they're both good the dog was
amazing doc and one with a Johnnie
Cochran I didn't see that one yes with
my man Cuba Gooding good I love Cuba all
right moving on to the next story
shoot Carla Johansson oh now you got
Steve's attention I love I love Jerry
Maguire Scarlett Johansson
I like Scarlett I know it's only a
matter of time before celebrity stalking
photographer paparazzi people do another
tragedy type of event like Princess Anna
Anna because they are going like they're
just getting increasingly dangerous yeah
there needs to be laws about that yeah
but you know like there-there are
necessary existence in Hollywood because
they help sighs they do yeah you know
what's funny way that they're going
about it she's saying is just dangerous
like but they do need them I was coming
from LAX one time and Dakota Fanning was
coming my god about her right of the
arrival section and the paparazzi was
waiting at that door at that time and I
thought there's no way you just know
she's coming the publicist tell
absolutely it was too random dude
they're waiting for adult Dakota Fanning
adult put a fanny like door number 14 of
arrivals there's no way that was Evans
I'm like yeah right of course you want
that picture I love that's like when
was running and I did this like secret
influencer it meet up and like they were
really like into like asking me a secret
you can't tell anybody we wants to be
really really low like on the DL like
whatever we get there and like
everything is like Hillary banners
everywhere like I'm with her and then
like there's these paparazzi everywhere
and there's like what up big CEOs like
oh yeah like abortion [ __ ] picketers
Oh smack like anti-abortion picketers
but like they're all have the same sign
and it look like there's like Dilek 20
of them I just like hi there hi we'll go
there to make Hillary look more badass
because it's like all of these people
are against abortion here I had a pop up
[ __ ] random rally that they put
together a top secret what's to be so
deal but there were tons of press there
tons of pop around oh my god see I
didn't work for the government because
if I was like oh secret meeting with
Hillary Clinton is gonna be in Chinatown
at this [ __ ] shitty ass like
restaurant in the back kitchen that's
the real secret there the whole time
she's just like it's so hot I can barely
talk there's like a guy [ __ ] on the
watch who's a guy killing a [ __ ]
chicken clucking it live dude that's a
real secret meeting right there yeah and
then you can like vlog that [ __ ] yo and
that'll go viral that's what I thought
it was gonna be yeah it was not I'm
gonna get to ask her some real questions
yeah they wouldn't even let Nikki ask a
question she had some dope question oh
yeah yeah they told us all the prepared
questions like to ask her and like you
can ask your audience like what you
would want to ask him stuff and they
hand selected people beforehand to ask
specific questions so she could have it
prepared so the whole thing is to make
it look like it was a pop-up and then
it's real time and we judged North Korea
yeah dude [ __ ] exactly yeah for doing
the same thing thank you exactly and
they got us all drunk on champagne
beforehand - dude are you ready for this
[ __ ] here this was the question that me
and he were like this would be sick to
ask it was like hey Hillary Clinton you
know how you say that like all these
people are against gay marriage and so
they're bigots well when you were
against gay marriage in 2008 was it cuz
he were a bigot then
what you said should have [ __ ] frozen
I don't think politicians have any
honest feelings about anything no they
don't just say whatever however the
current polling is yeah cuz normal was
against gay marriage at first maybe hey
we off that now we off that man guy it
is I forget what I used to say like it's
whatever whatever is popular to say I
remember in 2004 when they had a gay
marriage thing in California I voted I
was like no one hate or whatever the
[ __ ] I voted for whatever the gay
marriage thing was and then it wasn't
cool then but then like like four years
later was like getting to be the coolest
[ __ ] ever yeah I don't know where if you
notice the two sides only fight over
civil issues not me not on real policy
and things that matter right when it
comes to their position taxes yeah
things like that it's pretty much the
same type it's the same party oh yeah it
might be slightly different and
different yeah but they both don't go
after the real no no that's why we go to
war at random places at random times
like we go to war with Libya we're going
to Venezuela right right whether you're
right or left
you're for oil you're for the
corporation's of this nation to invade
and take oil yeah it doesn't matter if
you're right or left the paparazzi might
kill people huh just real quick I don't
care about people always say people
always say that what we're saying is
super cynical and [ __ ] but I'm like nah
dude it's not cynical it's what's
actually real you can't Gable that is
Ming or not like whatever when the real
[ __ ] is how about everybody that's dying
over oil
how about onna Tesla good point
it's like this like I own a Tesla we're
changing the channel the Kardashians is
on I'll of it
one more thing real quick everyone voted
for the Iraq war sir I'm saying in
Congress except for Dennis Kucinich and
Ron Paul he said no last story now Ron
Paul makes me think of RuPaul do battle
royale ladies waters said Hillary
Clinton no it was about the event - Sam
it was yes do you guys remember we
talked about this website called hush
hush calm which is the Amazon for
millionaires we talked about it oh I
remember yeah millionaires use Amazon no
no it's like a bike Ariana [ __ ]
private jets property it's like it went
in nicob I don't think I've ever felt so
girly I know right they broke at the
spate of my my friends they are now
asking quote can you help design a
battle royale inspired arena for a last
person standing contest oh [ __ ] they're
gonna do deaf people die what is this
we've got a movie so it is a money man
movie right yeah yeah with
Schwarzenegger they try to do that in
Russia actually looks like a Hunger
Games kind of thing that's what happens
we have too much money here just like us
what if like somebody died and we got to
watch it that is what they used to do
with like slavery
and like in like Django alright that's
like billionaires today I guarantee you
they're [ __ ] taking poor people out
to a desert and hunting them I agree 36
billion pity been you can't just nothing
you can't buy a house remember that
movie hostel oh oh I just don't want to
stay in hostels because there's a lot of
smelly do you remember those bodies
those bodies museums where you can see
the human body and all the [ __ ] we're
gonna go to that in Vegas yes so guess
what dude a lot of that [ __ ] they found
out that it was Falun Gong like Chinese
dissidents and they're killing these
people and then selling them into these
[ __ ] [ __ ] crazy but I've seen that
the bodies that you're looking at it's
like Chinese dissidents but now I want
to see it more because like a called
religion good point Falun Gong good hook
isn't it it's a it might be an outlawed
cult group religion and and I think they
might have killed them and if that's
what they're saying that they're looking
for someone who can help design an arena
for a 100 person battle royale inspired
event and the whoever designs this will
get a forty five thousand british pound
contract which is about like 80 grand
like sixty thousand dollars and so
they're saying that at the end o be a
100,000 pound jackpot which is about 130
thousand dollars for just a design of
the place no no first the last person
standing for this event is a hundred a
hundred thousand town jackpot so they're
saying that this will be twelve hours of
competition each day Jesus three-day
events they will camp for the night food
and camping gear will be required this
is not actual like killing what is it
like airsoft or something it's airsoft
guns ammo and touch-sensitive body arms
Oh that'd be fine it's for tonight yeah
oh yeah in real life yeah well you got a
run though dude you can be maker that's
pretty dope I mean they already have
these four uh air slot like they go
full-on like seven days yeah straight up
airsoft games I wish they would remake a
rat race that movie rat
love looks like you got to go to Vegas
every time I read something like this
about millionaires trying to do some
[ __ ] I always think about its agreement
cuz that's more like you know scavenger
hunt II and I like that [ __ ] wait do
they leave Vegas or they go to Vegas I
forgot
thank go to Vegas they go to [ __ ] okay
are there in Vegas and then they leave
Vegas yeah yeah yeah okay they gotta
find some Locker yeah yeah yeah and like
Arizona section wow that's way better
than escape rubs that's why I say [ __ ]
escape rooms
hashtag [ __ ] is both isn't that kind of
what amazing amazing race's kind of Oh
true it is yeah you gotta think and it's
for everyone's a minute let's escape
room I was just like after walls like
yeah this is dumb this is so not smart I
bought everything me too I was like my
friends were smart I was like no no I'm
not good how you filter dude if I was in
like a I'm the guy you don't want me to
never got out of the first world talking
I'm not gonna do it you and me we should
do da Vinci Code movie with two dumb
[ __ ] who can never get upside down for
the first hour in an escape room yeah
dude [ __ ] yeah really get out it just
dies all bad at puzzles I got so fresh I
mean this is stupid anyway man let's go
bowling me dude I might at least give me
something to drink in here dude this I
love it I'm stimulated by scape me too I
hate it I like escape rooms let me out
[Music]